bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
pour cette petite réaction à un trailer
aujourd'hui on va se faire life on est
en planète un documentaire Netflix qui
normalement devrait sortir cet automne
donc Netflix bon c'est les documentaires
Netflix a pas trop commenter là-dessus
on en a déjà fait on a déjà bien parler
avec mandax la dernière fois Netflix
avait quand même une certaine réputation
niveau documentaire mais celui-là
celui-là je l'ai déjà vu ce petit
trailer et honnêtement je sens qu'il va
être bien donc j'ai pas l'intention de
devenir une chaîne de réaction à des
trailers ou à des dos à des
documentaires en particulier mais
celui-là quand j'ai vu le trailer
il a il a il a ce petit côté
préhistorique planète en fait et j'ai
comme l'impression que effectivement
c'est ce que j'espérais avec préhistoric
Planet et du coup je suis content
préhistorique planète ça devient le
nouveau standard à atteindre pour les
documentaires et préhistorique planète
était très très réaliste avec des
interventions de paléontologue notamment
dans la saison 2 à la fin de la saison 2
donc
et puis tout ça a été évidemment là les
paléontologues étaient vraiment écoutés
quoi on sentait que c'était vraiment que
les paléontologues étaient vraiment
écoutés on sentait que les modèles
étaient vraiment très bien fait qu'ils
avaient mis du travail du temps il y
avait de la passion voilà il y avait de
la passion derrière et ça se sentait dès
le trailer pour préhistorique planète
donc là là j'ai ressenti un petit peu
cette chose là donc je vous invite à
aller voir le ce trailer avant parce que
moi évidemment je vais m'arrêter tous
les trois minutes pour commenter allez
voir le trailer d'abord puis revenez sur
cette vidéo je vous laisse deux secondes
dans la vidéo est pas en pause c'est
juste moi qui fait le clown bref allez
on se lance pour cette petite cette
petite vidéo
on commence sur des œufs des œufs que je
crois être d'émeu les œufs bleus verts
comme ça ça a l'air d'être des œufs des
mœurs qu'ils ont utilisé
alors oui je sais Steven Spielberg c'est
un grand nom mais c'est qu'un producteur
exécutif vous vous enflammez pas ça va
pas être réalisé par Steven Spielberg il
a juste mis du pognon c'est tout bon il
a du coup un mot à dire sur la qualité
du documentaire en général mais c'est
pas réalisé par Steven Spielberg ne nous
enflammons pas
ça va pas être le petit dinosaure et la
vallée des Merveilles
alors bon on a des dinosaures
on a quelques prises en images réelles
donc ça c'est pas mal oh bah attends ça
ça ressemble à on va avoir du mégalodon
on va avoir du mégalodon alors vous
voyez ce qui a d'intéressant avec ce
documentaire c'est qu'il va pas couvrir
que les dinosaures contrairement à
préhistorique planète qui restait comme
je m'en étais un petit peu plat au
niveau de la saison 2
préhistorique planète était resté dans
sa zone de confort au niveau des
dinosaures là ce documentaire il va
exploser explorer plusieurs périodes
donc là je pense que ça va être
mégalodon encore qu'il est possible que
ce soit très toxicrina et qu'on soit
toujours autant des dinosaures du coup
donc là on est au Trias avec les
tricératops on a un petit droméosaure
bien sympa bien plumeur regardez la
qualité quand même de la modélisation et
elle est quand même pas mal du tout quoi
ce que j'avais déjà dit par rapport aux
écailles et tout ça à propos de de
préhistorique planète bah là c'est
pareil là on voit on voit que
préhistoric Planet vraiment a eu son
influence sur le format documentaire et
que maintenant les documentaires vont
essayer d'atteindre cette qualité donc
là pareil la qualité de la modélisation
est excellente là la qualité
scientifique de ce petit droméosaure à
part le fait qu'il est tout blanc et que
pour l'instant on n'a jamais trouvé de
au niveau dinosaure à plumes on en a
jamais trouvé aucun qui ne portait pas
de trace de mélanine dans ses plumes
donc là c'est à peu près la seule chose
qu'on peut reprocher à ce petit
droméosaure je pense en plus que c'est
un micro Raptor parce que il a donc ça
ça doit être Tarbosaurus du coup si
c'est un micro Raptor comme d'habitude
je me j'ai fait tout mon possible pour
ne pas être spoilé donc je n'ai aucune
idée de de des animaux qui ont qui vont
mettre dedans mais là on s'a sent le
Tarbosaurus à l'arrière et donc ça ça
sent le micro Raptor parce qu'on voit la
deuxième
paire d'elle sur les jambes donc c'est
pour ça que ça sent le micro à tort et
micro Raptor on sait que c'est plumes
sont très très riches en mélanine
puisqu'on a réussi à les voir puis de
toute façon ça se voit sur le spécimen
tel qu'il est préservé ça on voit assez
bien on voit assez bien que les plumes
sont noires bref donc micro Raptor
ah et là c'est le moment qui m'a IP
c'est un thérapide mesdames et messieurs
c'est un thérapide c'est pour ça que je
suis hyper
[Rires]
ceci mesdames et messieurs n'est pas un
gorgone obtient je croyais aussi que
c'était un gorgonopsien mais le nombre
de dents ne colle pas ça ne marche pas
avec le nombre de dents notamment le
nombre d'incisives donc c'est et en plus
quand on regarde le sommet du crâne vous
voyez ce trait ici c'est là où les
muscles temporaux s'insèrent donc en
fait vous avez deux muscles temporaux
qui s'insèrent comme ça au niveau d'une
crête sagitale et donc ça crée ces deux
boss sur les côtés cette petite crête au
milieu enfin cette petite galerie cette
cette gouttière au milieu et ça mesdames
et messieurs c'est le signe que nous
avons un animal avec une craie de
sagitale or les gorgones obtiens n'ont
pas de crade sagittal donc ça c'est pas
un gorgone obsia je suis pas sûr de ce
que c'est mais c'est pas un gorgone
optien j'ai deux hypothèses la première
c'est que ce soit un terreaucéphale
possiblement Mosco Vénus et là le et là
le contre le compte d'incisive marche le
problème c'est qu'on va voir après il a
des molaires si on regarde si on
continue un petit peu
on regarde les molaires voilà regardez
le nombre de molaires ici ça marche pas
pour moscoingus
donc je pensais que ce serait Mosco
Vénus et en fait là où
à mon avis ce qu'ils ont fait en fait
c'est qu'ils ont pris un cynodon et la
raison pour laquelle je dis ça c'est pas
parce que j'ai une vraie bonne raison de
le dire c'est parce qu'il lui ont collé
des poils
or scientifiquement on devrait pas
coller des poils à ces animaux là parce
que bah parce que on a aucune preuve de
poil et on a même on est même en train
d'accumuler de plus en plus d'épreuves
du contraire des preuves qu'il n'en
n'avaient pas de poils donc si vous
m'écoutez depuis longtemps si vous me
connaissez vous savez que ça fait très
longtemps que je dis arrêtez de coller
des moustaches au thérapie s'il vous
plaît Paléo artistes ce n'est pas la
peine de mettre des poils à vos
thérapsine on a pas de preuve de
présence de poils chez les thérapies et
on commence à accumuler de plus en plus
de preuves d'absence de poils chez les
thérapies j'ai été rapide non ma malien
bien sûr je précise donc là à mon avis
ils ont utilisé les poils pour montrer
qu'il s'agissait d'un animal qui était
relativement proche des mammifères donc
à mon avis ces poils sont une indication
qu'on va avoir le droit à un sinodonde
le truc c'est que c'est un synodonte qui
est qui a l'air très gros apparemment
qui a l'air bon il est représenté assez
c'est redoutable il est représenté assez
méchant donc c'est un synodontes
prédateur et c'est un synodontes qui a
un muffle très très épais donc soit
c'est synonyme nature et dans ce cas là
on va avoir une scène au milieu du Trias
soit c'est vétusodont et alors là s'ils
ont fait vétusodon je m'incline parce
que vetusodon il est pas vieux à ça fait
pas longtemps qu'il a été décrivé tuodon
donc s'ils ont inclu vêtus aux dons dans
leur documentaire
chapeau bas bravo vous avez mon respect
j'espère que ce sera vetus aux autres
j'espère franchement que ce sera vêtus
dedans mais là ça se voit vu comme ça je
ne suis qu'un paléontologue quand vous
mettez de la viande sur mes os je
reconnais plus rien
je ne pense pas que ce soit si non que
natus parce que les molaires sont très
très simples si c'était sinon une nature
on verrait quand même des molaires un
poil plus complexes mais bon on verra on
verra mais en tout cas c'est super cool
il y a des thérapies et justement c'est
ce que je disais la variété qui manquait
après historique planète cette variété
de de d'animaux cette variété d'époque
là on explorait que la toute fin du
Crétacé avec play historique planète là
on va aller au permis on va aller au
Trias là ils vont nous faire voyager là
mais c'est beau et c'est bon mais oui
faites-moi voyager dans le temps et dans
l'espace mais oui
alors toujours cette façon de mettre des
lèvres
toujours cette façon de mettre des
bonnes grosses lèvres en plus des lèvres
qui ont l'air de se rétracter si je ne
m'abuse
donc des lèvres qui se rétractent ça par
contre ils avaient pas même les
synododes
les lèvres rétractables c'était pas
quelque chose que les synodontes avaient
on a on a à peu près toutes les bonnes
raisons de penser qu'ils étaient
similaires au reptiles de ce point de
vue là alors soit ils avaient pas du
tout de lèvres comme les crocodiles soit
ils avaient des des lèvres mais juste un
petit une petite fine
un farido d'écailles qui couvrait les
lèvres le rideau d'écailles étant une
hypothèse qu'on ne peut pas vérifier
mais du coup et qui est non nécessaire
quoi jusqu'à preuve du contraire vaut
mieux pas mettre de lèvres ou du moins
si vous êtes Paléo artistes encore une
fois c'est pas la peine de vous
formaliser trop à savoir s'il y avait
des lèvres ou pas vous avez le droit à
peu près de faire ce que vous voulez
contrairement à ce que certains disent
ce n'est pas plus scientifique de mettre
des lèvres non mais là il est beau là et
puis regardez la texture de la peau elle
est quand même bon bah ils ont mis un
petit peu de poils oui bon je suis pas
super pour mais la texture de la peau
est globalement
une peau un peu de cochon quoi ce qui
est quand même ce vers quoi on a
tendance à aller aujourd'hui au niveau
des reconstructions donc ça c'est bien
ça c'est bien
je j'ai vraiment ça me perturbe en fait
de pas savoir ce que c'est cette animal
mais voilà allez je mets mes billes je
vais je vais prendre une deuxième voilà
je mets mes billes sur vetuso donc voilà
je crois en toi Netflix vas-y fais-moi
rêver
des tirsland sabre le tigres à dents de
sabre bon on connaît pas on connaît pas
leur
on connaît pas qu'elle était leur
pelage de quoi a été fait leur pelage
donc là ils les ont fait avec des tâches
pourquoi pas je pense que du coup ils
vont nous faire voyager en Amérique du
Nord au playstos saine aussi du coup si
on va voir si s'il s'agit bien d'un
semiodon on va voyager en Amérique du
Nord au playstosène on a donc les
mammouths qui suivent c'est en Amérique
du Nord on a Mamoutou ce Colombie qui a
aussi là
évidemment les T-Rex des T-Rex
on ne va pas se passer de T-Rex
évidemment ah là ils ont fait T-Rex
modèle chunky le modèle gras
là celui-là il a même un double menton
on dirait donc là on a eu le droit à
des T-Rex et qui communiquent avec leurs
tronche regardez ce qu'ils font là ce
que ne faisait pas non plus
préhistorique planète
ils sont en train de se frotter le
visage l'un sur l'autre et ça c'est
comme ça que les T-Rex devaient
communiquer de se frotter la tronche et
mordre parce que c'est là qu'il y a
beaucoup de sensibilité dans leur visage
là on voit les nerfs dans l'os qui qui
arrive à ce niveau-là d'ailleurs ils ont
fait ça très granuleux ici là donc là là
ça c'est une vraie manière de communion
enfin c'est une belle manière bien basée
sur les données qu'on a de faire
communiquer les tirs exports en leur
faisant faire des parades nuptiales où
il montre leur gorge là
non ça c'est sorti nulle part
montrez-nous des T-Rex qui se frottent
les uns sur les autres et puis des T-Rex
donc qui ont en plus du rouge là sur
leur crête parce qu'ils ont une crête
sur le nez qui leur monte jusqu'au
dessus des yeux donc les T-Rex avec la
crête qui monte jusque sur les œufs ça
colorés en rouge pendant la parade
nuptiale ça c'est ça a du sens tout ça
ça a du sens là pour l'instant on est à
30 secondes de cette minute 23 de de
de trailer et honnêtement je suis je
suis confiant je suis confiant il y a du
bon pour l'instant il y a du bon
alors évidemment on va nous montrer
l'extinction des dinosaures on ne fait
pas une scène au Crétacé
et on va nous montrer l'origine de la
vis ça va être si diversifié que ça
enfin on va avoir une telle variété de
d'habitats qui vont nous être présentés
que on va même remonter jusqu'à
l'origine de la vie apparemment j'espère
qu'il nous demande pas j'espère qu'ils
vont pas juste dire la vie la vie est
apparue il y a 4 milliards d'années
direction le créateur maintenant et
merde
donc oui j'espère que c'est pas une
douille qui soit en train de nous mettre
et qui vont vraiment faire un épisode
sur l'origine de la vie vraiment un
épisode sur le permis et le Trias la
grande extinction de masse lui permet un
Trias vraiment un épisode sur le Crétacé
qui se terminera par l'extinction des
dinosaures est vraiment un épisode sur
le Le Play stoessen avec les mammouths
avec les tigres à dents de sabre là
j'espère que ils ne mettent pas une
douille en mode ils vont nous passer ça
ils vont passer 15 minutes sur tout le
reste et cinq épisodes que sur les
dinosaures quoi mais ouais là ça ça
c'est prometteur c'est prometteur
ceci dit ça veut dire que c'est un très
bon trailer s'ils ont fait ça on aura
même le droit au devenir enfin peut-être
plus le Carbonifère parce que
alors là ça ressemble à eux c'était
notre Terron ça ça donc c'était un petit
rond qui est un qui est donc un poisson
sarcoptergien c'est poisson à nageoires
charnu donc là ils ont très très bien
représenté la nageoire charnu on
reconnaît la forme générale d'un
osteénoptéron
et là on a un amphibien qui m'a l'air
d'être un luminosélis si je ne m'abuse
ça ressemble en tout cas pas mal à
l'hypnose hélice alors on a un amphibien
qui a l'air très très avancé ce qui du
coup est pas vraiment enfin à moins il
se soit juste des diagnostes en fait
peut-être que c'est que peut-être que je
suis en train de m'enflammer à appeler
ça de sténoptéron peut-être que là c'est
censé être que des dips je sais pas je
dis Dino c'était d'hypnose de façon
complètement interchangeable donc ne
soyez pas perturbé c'est juste la forme
de la queue en fait
[Musique]
la queue est légèrement épicière car il
est pas impossible à épicer que ça veut
dire que il y a une pointe vers le haut
donc elle est pas complètement difficile
la queue donc peut-être que c'est un
dipneuste primitif du coup
peut-être je sais pas mais même si
c'était un d'hypnose primitive ce serait
de venir la raison pour laquelle je
m'inquiète c'est que si c'est
l'hymnosélis ce truc là c'est plus on
est beaucoup plus avancé dans le temps
là on est carbonifère
carbonifère bien tapé en fait le truc
avec cette animal là c'est que il a déjà
les yeux sur le côté donc moi je pars du
principe que c'est un amphibien parce
que je pense qu'on est en train de nous
montrer du dévonia mais si c'est un
amphibien c'est déjà un amphibien
reptilio morphe c'est déjà un amphibien
qui commence à devenir un reptile parce
que au lieu d'avoir les yeux sur le
sommet du crâne comme les amphibiens
sont censés là-bas il a les yeux sur le
côté donc pour moi ça ressemble à
l'hypnosélis qui fait partie des
reptilesmorphes mais dans ce cas là on
est beaucoup plus tapé direction
carbonifère voire même Permien parce que
l'hypnose hélice en réalité il est du
Permien donc on a déjà des reptiles
morts il me semble à la fin du
Carbonifère mais si c'est effectivement
l'hypnosélis en réalité on est même
carrément dans le Permien dans le
Permien il y a des dix pneuses on a des
dipns ici dans en Afrique du Sud des
terriers au moins de 10
dans le carreau donc il est pas
impossible qu'on est qu'on soit face
donc un reptilio morphe donc un ancêtre
des reptiles un animal de la transition
entre amphibiens et reptiles qui soit en
train de se délecter de quelques dipns
ou alors si ils ont fait une un énorme
s'ils ont fait un énorme raccourci
raccourci au niveau du temps ce sera un
osténoptéron en tout cas c'est pareil on
agrandit la variété de paysages qu'on va
voir et de et de scène qu'on va avoir
donc j'espère qu'on va avoir un épisode
entier bon évidemment un arthrope le
rides probablement arthropera un
orthosphère mesdames et messieurs on
aura aussi de leur domicien regardez-moi
cette orthocert géant enfin je suppose
que l'idée c'est de comprendre qu'il est
géant puisque là on a des coraux qui
sont déjà on l'imagine assez gros un
orthocert géant mesdames et messieurs
donc on va aussi avoir du dévonia mais
il y a combien d'épisodes dans cette
série
combien il y a d'épisodes
non mais sérieux là on a on a déjà donc
l'origine de la ville lors de vicien le
Permien le
dévonia peut-être le plié au playstocène
du Crétacé avec l'extinction des
dinosaures enfin là je suis magnifique
c'est excellent du mégalodon peut-être
qu'on avait dit si c'est pas très
toxicillinat du coup
là Netflix honnêtement il se foutent pas
de nous
donc très jolie sert un qu'on reconnaît
évidemment c'est c'est un mollusque avec
une énorme coquille
une énorme coquille droite non pas
enroulée comme les ammonites et puis on
reconnaît que c'est un orthocert parce
que ils l'ont fait beaucoup de bras 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 ouais il y en a
peut-être pas tant que ça en réalité
mais il y a beaucoup de bras ce qui est
plutôt un truc des nautilloïdes et pas
un truc qu'on retrouve chez les
mollusques qui en ont enfin chez les
les décapodes et les octopodes qui sont
des mollusques beaucoup plus dérivés du
coup et qui ont des un nombre de bras
beaucoup plus réduits ceci étant dit
j'ai pas vraiment vu exactement combien
il y avait de bras et on en voit pas
tant que ça au final donc
ça a l'air de confirmer qu'on va avoir
un épisode au déjeunon tout ça d'accord
et un truc qui manquait aussi après
historique planète des cabossures
regardez là regardez là la tête du
dingléostéus il y a des cabosses dessus
ça on sent qu'il a vécu notre d'un
cleosteus là c'est ce qui manquait
beaucoup
après historique planète c'est qu'on
avait vraiment l'impression que il
voyait les dinosaures ils sortaient de
la production voilà il sortait de du
moule ils étaient encore tout frais tout
chaud ils avaient aucune trace aucune
cicatrice rien du tout là voilà là vous
me montrez un teint cléostheus qui a
vécu là ça là c'est beau là c'est beau
ah et donc on va nous vendre l'idée
qu'apparemment d'un clé osteus se
baladait en famille ce qui serait plus
ou moins
plus ou moins basé on va dire sur le
fait que certains représentants de de la
famille des placoderm arthrodir dont
laostus fait partie certains
représentants
enfin ne pondez pas d'oeuf quoi de
donner naissance à des petits
directement formés ce qui est plutôt une
caractéristique de poisson plutôt évolué
plutôt avancé
donc qu'on dont on peut faire un
raccourci en disant bah s'il avait ça se
comportement là qui était avancé
pourquoi pas un comportement de vie en
famille
ou alors c'est juste les petits qui
vivent au crochet de la maman c'est
juste les petits qui suivent maman et
puis qui qui boulote ses restes quand
elle tue quelque chose ce possible aussi
c'est on pourrait ce serait un semi
parasitisme plutôt qu'un qu'une preuve
de soins familiaux là je sais pas je
verrai on verra bien ce qu'il nous
vendent d'ailleurs le design de
dakleyostéus alors c'est dur à c'est dur
de se rendre compte avec l'absence
d'échelle évidemment mais ce design de
d'un cleosteus on sent que c'est un d'un
cleosteus modèle raccourci j'ai comme
l'impression qu'ils ont suivi la
littérature scientifique récente et
qu'ils nous ont fait un d'un Clio ostéus
qui du coup ne fera pas plus de
4-5 mètres de long maximum
un dacléostéus donc au lieu d'avoir un
inclusostus très allongé très profilé
très hydrodynamique on va avoir un
inclusteus plutôt court plutôt tassé en
fait un animal qui faisait plutôt des
des pointes de vitesse sur de courtes
distances plutôt qu'un animal qui était
qui va faire des longues distances à une
vitesse de croisière raisonnable donc ça
c'est bien là c'est bien et là c'est là
qu'on vous me perdez le varan de Komodo
évidemment on fait un film on fait un
documentaire sur les dinosaures en vous
sort un varan de Komodo
[Rires]
je sais pas ce qu'ils vont faire de
Komodo mais là je vous surveille
faisez pas n'importe quoi avec le varan
de Komodo commencez pas à dire que c'est
un que c'est une relique du temps des
dinosaures ou un descendants des
dinosaures je ne sais quoi je vous
regarde je vous préviens les varans de
Komodo rien à voir avec les dinosaures
rien à voir avec les dinosaures donc je
sais pas ce que vous allez en faire de
se voir de Komodo si c'est pour nous
parler de mégalania en Australie ou je
sais pas quoi mais faisait gaffe
disez pas que c'est un dinosaure le
varan de Komodo disait pas que c'est un
dinosaure parce que si vous le disez
oui je sais c'est vous le dites mais je
fais le crétin si vous le disez
attention attention
vous allez entendre parler de moi
[Rires]
ah bah voilà le fameux le fameux supposé
micro Raptor en train de planer avec ses
4L
d'ailleurs ah ouais pareil la position
des jambes en fait ça ça va donc ils ont
montré au départ on représentait micro
Raptor qui me qui mettait vraiment ses
jambes complètement à l'horizontale pour
pouvoir utiliser ces ailes postérieures
à meilleure escient et en fait il y a
des études qui ont montré que non ils
pouvaient pas l'articulation des jambes
permettait pas d'écarter les jambes à ce
point là comme les dinosaures modernes
les dinosaures modernes ne peuvent pas
faire le grand écart donc l'articulation
des jambes ne leur permet pas mais du
coup là j'ai l'impression qu'ils en ont
tenu compte et que du coup ils ont gardé
quand même un écartement de jambes qui
était
modérée bon maintenant on a quand même
un micro Raptor animal plutôt arboricole
plutôt habitué à la forêt en train de se
faire du Best jump depuis une falaise
peut-être que c'est suite à la
pourchasse peut-être que c'est après
avoir été pourchassé par le tarbesaurus
et qu'il a pas le choix et qu'il se
jette de la falaise c'est ça ou se faire
bouffer quoi et là dans ce cas là
pourquoi pas mais on est on est bien
d'accord que le digue que le design 4L
de micro Raptor s'est fait pour planer
sur de très courte distance et c'est
vraiment un planage qui devait pas être
hyper efficace donc là je pense pas
qu'il faisait ça tous les jours notre
micro Raptor du base jump du haut des
falaises mais ceci dit ça donne de
belles images regardez c'est trop trop
beau les mammouths ah donc on aura des
tigres à dents de sabre maintenant aussi
des lions des cavernes du coup très bien
des nuances des cavernes qui sont de
plus représentées sans crinière parce
que grâce aux grâce aux peintures
rupestres on sait que les loups des
cavernes étaient blancs et n'avaient pas
de crinière donc ça c'est très très bien
c'est très très bien représenté et on
les représente en train de vivre en de
vivre en
ordre enfin on dit pas une horde pour un
lion mais bref vous voyez ce que je veux
dire en vivre en groupe bon bah comme
les Lions modernes donc ça encore ça se
défend
et le listrosaurus celui-là je l'ai
partagé sur Twitter parce que qu'est-ce
que j'étais content de voir pour la
première fois un listrosaurus bien foutu
dans un documentaire ah ça fait du bien
le listrosaurus le survivant de la
limite permet à ce qui me fait
définitivement penser qu'on va avoir un
épisode sur la crise permiatriaque parce
qu'on ne peut pas parler de
l'hystrosaurus sans parler de la crise
permienrias d'ailleurs on aura peut-être
même en fait ce sera peut-être un
épisode thématique sur les extinctions
je me demande si ce sera pas ça mais
bref ce serait vraiment super qu'on a un
épisode sur listosaurus parce que
seulllistosaurus il est magnifique c'est
exactement à ça alors ça m'a l'air
d'être un lysosaurus du Trias parce que
une fois de plus il a l'air ça m'a l'air
pardon d'être un lysosaurus du Permien
donc l'histoire
il est balaise il est il a l'air assez
costaud apparemment une fois de plus on
souffre d'une absence de barre d'échelle
permettant d'être complètement
affirmatif mais il a l'air assez costaud
assez bien bâti il a un très très long
museau ce qu'on retrouve chez
listrotsaurus mckegy mais qu'on retrouve
aussi chez une espèce de lysosaurus du
Trias donc peut-être que voilà
si ce listrosaurus a vécu avec l'autre
thérapie qu'on a vu avant là le
carnivore
il est possible du coup ça exclut
immédiatement si nos gnatus donc ne
reste plus que Mosco Vénus ou vetuso
donc du coup pour le carnivore
intéressant on verra bien comme je
disais on verra bien mais je garde mes
billes sur vetuzodon donc un bon
listrosaurus possiblement du Trias bien
reconstitué le bec remonte entre les
narines exactement ce qu'on voit sur les
fossiles sur les fossiles on n'a pas le
bec le bec est pas préservé mais on a
les petits trous qui amenaient du sang à
la kératine du bec parce que le bec
c'est un bec il grandit en continu
donc il fallait un approvisionnement
sans régulier pour ce bec pour que ce
bec puisse continuer de grandir et donc
on arrive à suivre en fait à la
distribution juste des petits trous pour
les vaisseaux sanguins dans le crâne on
arrive à voir où était le bec chez
istrothory c'est donc on sait qu'il se
que au milieu il remontait entre les
narines donc là c'est parfait et que sur
les côtés il remontait par dessus les
canines donc sur les processus
caniformes comme on le voit ici donc ça
c'est parfait c'est un magnifique
lysosaurus la texture de la peau une
fois de plus elle est très très belle
elle est très réussie elle est
légèrement granuleuse j'espère que la
résolution est assez bonne de votre côté
pour que vous puissiez vous en
convaincre mais la texture de la peau
est légèrement granuleuse exactement
comme les momies de l'hystrosaurus qui
ont été décrites l'année dernière où il
y a deux ans je sais plus mais c'était
il y a pas longtemps exactement comme
sur les momies de l'hystrosaurus vous
imaginez on a des momies de 250 millions
d'années de cet animal donc ils ont pu
se baser dessus pour faire une belle
texture granuleuse de la peau
pas un seul poil voilà de quoi je parle
il n'y a pas de poil sur liste rosaurus
malheureusement puisqu'on a les momies
tout entière il y a pas une il n'y a pas
un seul poil dessus donc
ce serait quand même contraire au
principe de parcimonie de coller des
poils c'est pas complètement stupide d'y
mettre des poils encore une fois si vous
êtes pas allé au artiste c'est pas
complètement stupide de mettre des poils
avant de l'islosaurus mais sachez que
encore une fois on a des momies entières
de l'hystroaurus il y a pas un poil
dessus donc c'est contraire au principe
de parcimonie alors vous pouvez inventer
avancer d'autres arguments mais
vous vous écartez de la science ce
faisant en mettant des poils sur
listrotaurus les bras sont semi écartés
les jambes sont droites exactement la
posture qu'on pense
qu'avait l'hystrosaurus on le pense
parce que j'avais fait une vidéo parce
que la structure des eaux indique que
les bras étaient en posture semi-érigée
alors que les jambes étaient en posture
complètement érigés et on le sait parce
que là j'ai carrément envie de dire on
le sait parce qu'on a des empreintes de
l'histoire et que ces empreintes
montrent que le pied s'imprimait de si
vous imaginez que ce bras là c'est le
sol voilà le pied s'imprimait comme ça
dans la dans la terre par contre le bras
lui quand il atterrissait sur le sol il
faisait ça il tournait et ensuite il se
soulevait et donc cette rotation du bras
enfin cette rotation de la main dans la
boue qui s'est imprimé dans ses fossiles
d'empreintes de l'histoire cette
rotation de la main dans la boue elle
est due au fait que quand on a une
posture sommier érigée ou complètement
ou complètement rampante donc exactement
ce que vous voyez là une posture semi
rampante juste pour la cohérence en fait
vous devez aller chercher devant et puis
quand vous poussez vous tournez
forcément le le poignet en fait
donc ça on le voit sur les empreintes et
ça c'est beau ils en ont tenu compte et
ça c'est beau c'est pas le listrosaurus
de Jurassic World oui je remets un
taquet Jurassic World ouais le listrot
Zaurus de Jurassic World il est
dégoûtant bon il avait la bonne posture
certes mais ça tronche quoi là il avait
une espèce de petit bec là juste au
dessus de la lèvre là c'était dégoûtant
c'était horrible
c'était horrible bon
listes enfin un beau lysos j'ai hâte de
voir cet épisode rien que pour cet
épisode j'ai envie j'ai envie de voir
cette série voilà ça y est c'est vous
voulez connaître mon avis rien que pour
l'épisode sur les thérapies je veux voir
cette série
bah on s'en fout des dinosaures
encore une fois des dinosaures dans la
flotte bon ça va ils sont pas ils sont
pas jusque le bidon dans la flotte non
plus mais
faites gaffe à vos soropodes dans la
flotte c'est pareil j'ai dit à Jurassic
World Jurassic World tu nous remets pas
les sauropodes dans l'eau hein donc
Netflix pareil tu nous remets pas les
sons repas dans l'eau bon là il a juste
il en a jusqu'au cheville ça va je passe
admettons
peut-être qu'ils vont nous montrer ce
serait intéressant qui nous montre une
scène ce sera intéressant vous voyez que
qu'on nous montre une scène en fait où
on voit un soropod nager et on voit
juste il y a que ses bras enfin il y a
que ses mains du coup qui touchent le
fond parce que les bras qui aux oridés
ils avaient les bras plus long que les
jambes donc il y a que les mains en fait
qui touchaient le fond et on a une
empreinte de pas enfin il a une piste de
brachiosauridé du coup avec juste les
mains qui touchent le fond c'est trop
marrant vous imaginez un brachiosaure
funambule mais c'est parce qu'il était
en train de nager en fait et du coup il
avait le cul relevé mais les sont
suffisamment long pour toucher le sol
donc peut-être qu'on va nous montrer ça
ce serait très drôle ce serait très
drôle c'est la seule et unique raison
pour laquelle vous aurez le droit de
mettre un son repode dans l'eau c'est
pour voir un brachiosaure nager voilà
c'est dit
attention attention
il y a le dragon de Komodo vous avez
perdu une vie déjà ce reporte dans l'eau
presque perdu de vie la troisième bon
ceci dit on entendait la voix du
commentateur arrivé dans la scène
suivante donc je pense que c'est la fin
il est rétro c'est regarder la posture
du T-Rex là ça fait ça fait super rétro
enfin moi j'adore mais
ça fait super rétro de voir un T-Rex
avec la tête relever la queue quasiment
au ras du sol comme ça ça fait hyper
rétro c'est peut-être ça la contribution
de Steven Spielberg c'est de nous
refaire un dent tranchante
ce serait trop bien qu'il l'appelle
tantranchante mais je j'hallucine
comment ils ont fait les T-Rex hyper
chunky en fait ça correspond à ce qui
était sorti il y a pas longtemps
on nous avait dit on a refait le T-Rex
le plus réaliste possible et
effectivement le l'une des
caractéristiques de cetirex c'était
d'être hyper gras quoi alors que on a
l'habitude de représenter les dinosaures
avec seulement la peau sur les eaux
notamment les carnivores là le T-Rex
qu'ils avaient reconstitué était hyper
gras on n'a pas plus de raison de penser
qu'ils étaient hyper gras que hyper
maigre c'est juste que la le fait de la
reconstituer hyper maigre bah encore une
fois on colle au maximum au squelette ce
qui est la chose qu'on a donc plus vous
rajoutez ensuite de tissu notamment du
muscle et des couches de graisse plus
vous faites des hypothèses c'est aussi
le problème qu'il y a avec les lèvres
c'est que plus vous rajoutez de tissu
autour de la bouche plus vous faites
d'hypothèse donc vous vous éloignez du
maximum de parcimonie qui serait de
mettre le moins de chair possible ceci
étant dit les muscles il faut quand même
les remettre quelque part mais voilà là
on a quand même un T-Rex qui est assez
funky c'est assez balèze
et dans une posture qui rappelle les
années 90 enfin la fin des années 80
même pour le petit dinosaure et donc la
vallée des merveilles qui se trouve à
ses pieds magnifique vallée des
Merveilles j'ai la vague sensation je
sais pas on est en Amérique là où on est
en Afrique parce que ça ça ressemble
quand même vachement au Wakanda
le Wakanda où on voit des scènes dans
Black Panther en fait ça se trouve en
Afrique du Sud et c'est le c'est le
Golden Gate National Park en Afrique du
Sud et ça ça ressemble quand même
vachement au Wakanda bon ceci dit il y a
rien qui ressemble plus à une montagne
engrais qu'une autre montagne engrais
une montagne engrais jaune entourée de
sapin donc bon on va on va rester
prudent sur la sur la géolocalisation de
cet endroit mais c'est c'est la grande
vallée la vallée des Merveilles la voilà
elle est ici et voici dans tranchante
enfin accepter voilà dans tranchante en
fait accepter dans la vallée des
merveilles magnifique et la voix du
commentateur je me demande si c'est pas
Morgan Freeman mais honnêtement je sais
pas
ça ressemble à la voix de Morgan Freeman
et donc oui octobre 25 octobre donc oui
la renaissance des documentaires Netflix
on l'espère on espère que ça va être la
renaissance des documentaires Netflix et
puis bah on l'attend on l'attend on
l'attend un petit peu au tournant là
pour le vendre commodo mais sinon on
l'attend voilà j'espère que ça vous a
plu je vous remercie d'avoir suivi cette
vidéo et puis bah on se dit à très
bientôt sur la chaîne salut